eine frage die man klar mit ja
beantworten muss ja die europäische
union wird zum überwachungsstaat wenn im
rechtsausschuss des eu-parlaments für
eine reform des urheberrechts gestimmt
wird dann werden upload filter wie
content id auf youtube nämlich zum
verpflichtenden zensur element und die
cdu treibt es voran obwohl im
koalitionsvertrag etwas ganz anderes
geregelt ist ein wichtiges thema wir
müssen etwas tun herzlich willkommen bei
pixum science fiction
das heute ein video quasi in eigener
sache eigentlich steht im
koalitionsvertrag zitat eine
verpflichtung von plattformen zum
einsatz von upload filtern um von
nutzern hochgeladenen inhalten nach
urheberrechtsverletzenden inhalte zu
filtern lehnen wir als unverhältnismäßig
ab trotzdem treibt der eu abgeordnete
axel voss von der cdu genau den voran
jetzt soll darüber abgestimmt werden und
weil einige rechtspopulistische parteien
mit der cdu stimmen sieht es danach aus
dass der vorschlag durchkommen dabei ist
der vorschlag von unkenntnis
durchdrungen und die macht es schon
heute filtern wie dem content id system
von youtube schwer im urheberrecht gibt
es das recht auf freie benutzung das
heißt ich darf ein neues werk unter der
benutzung eines existierenden werkes
erstellen zb kann ich filmausschnitte
neu zusammenschneiden
dies muss immer zur schaffung eines
neuen werkes führen best of und so
weiter das ist verboten - dagegen sind
genau das und explizit erlaubt ein
automatischer filter dagegen kann das
nicht unterscheiden eine wichtige
grundlage der entwicklung der kultur
wird torpediert und es gibt das
zitatrecht um thesen in videos artikeln
und so weiter zu belegen dann darf ich
filmausschnitte fotos und texte
verwenden ein filter kann auch das nicht
unterscheiden zudem ist ein solches
allgemeines monitoring laut
rechtsprechung des europäischen
gerichtshofes verboten
die befürworter argumentieren das würde
ja immer einzeln nach bestimmten
parteien gesucht aber das eben überall
und allgemein so ein quatsch also das
ist allgemeines monitoring zudem wird
die privatsphäre verletzt und der
datenschutz damit sich die user
beschweren können müssen deren daten
gesammelt werden
geht nicht anders und schon heute
funktionieren beschwerde mechanismen
nicht weil zum beispiel youtube komplett
überfordert ist zuweilen dauertest tage
ein fälschlicherweise gesperrt das video
frei zu bekommen oder einen gelöschten
kanal wieder frei zu bekommen
ich sage nur dattel täter und open mind
und leider funktioniert das nur mit
massiver intervention kann ich aus
eigener erfahrung sagen und die normalen
wege
die bringen da gar nichts und schon
heute werden diese systeme missbraucht
der zugriff auf content id hat der ist
versucht kritische beiträge über sich zu
löschen und genau das soll auch schon
passiert sein wenn er beweise dafür habt
schickt mir den video
ling und am besten das skript auf rezept
ich sehe mir das video dann über das
youtube back end an vielleicht kann ich
sogar etwas tun und ganz am rande seien
auch das leistungsschutzrecht erwähnt §
11 in deutschland gescheitert soll es
jetzt europaweit die bezahlung von
verlinkungen erzwingen teilen gehört
dann der vergangenheit an man man man
alles in allem geht da was in die
komplett falsche richtung wir müssen
etwas tun und ihr könnt ist unten in der
video beschreibung habe ich die petition
von change.org verlinkt bitte unbedingt
unterschreiben es geht um unsere
freiheit auf whatsapp schicke ich euch
eine nachricht die bitte an möglichst
viele leute einfach weiterleitet und sie
bittet sie wiederum weiterzuleiten
tretet eine lawine los und unten in der
video beschreibung habe ich noch einen
text reinkopiert in der zukunft ist das
ja nicht mehr erlaubt den ihr eurem oder
eurer eu-abgeordneten mail schicken
können zu whatsapp kommt ihr über diesen
link bitte folgt mehr da und macht mit
diesen irrsinn zu stoppen einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klick zum social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klingen
aber nicht die dem auge noch vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken anonymus was ist axa ja da
war doch mal was man bis das bleibt an